[Music]
imagine it's a bright sunny day and the
temperature seems to be rising gradually
what kind of outfit will you prefer
while going out in the Sun light and
soft cotton clothes that's what I would
choose
same holds true for furnishing we would
prefer soft and comfortable bed sheets
and pillow covers made up of cotton many
such amazing applications make thought
in the most integral part of her lives
and also the first choice among other
fibers so where does the story of cotton
begin it begins from these soft spongy
balls seen on the cotton plant let's get
started with them the cotton plants
require a lot of sunshine and a
typically tropical climate with medium
rainfall once the cotton ball which is
the fruit like structure containing the
cotton fibers matures it bursts open and
the snow-white cotton fibers are exposed
these bolts are collected and drawn into
yarns but wait don't you think we need
to separate the seats and the soft
fluffy part first well that can be
carried out either manually or these
days mostly with the use of machines the
process of separating the seeds and the
fibers is called as giving one skinning
is successfully carried out the fibers
are taken for the next step the next
step is spinning what do we mean by
spinning it's simply the process of
making yarn from fibres remember the
series fibers make up yarn and yon makes
the fabric so fibers are the naturally
occurring threads these need to be drawn
into long and continuous filaments these
long filaments are the yarns and these
yarns are the ones that are woven into
fabrics so spinning is the process where
the threads are converted into yarns but
how is this done if you take a cotton
thread between your palms and press it
gently by rolling it this way what you
get is a slender long filament like
structure this is nothing but yawn
we note that there are tons of threads
that are spun into yarn every day but if
this is how spinning occurs then imagine
the amount of effort needed to make yarn
out of so much of cotton how is it done
then of course there are machines which
help us do that in countries like India
since many years the traditional
equipments like charka were used however
with the advancement in the field of
technology newer machines to spin the
threads into yarn are now available with
this we complete the first major step of
cotton collection and spinning the
thread into yarn now we need to make
fabric out of the yarn let's see that in
the next video
[Music]